have you ever asked yourself the
question why haven't I done the things I
wanted to do not listen to the naysayers
purpose is that a hidden seed of
greatness stop procrastinating focus on
your goal
nothing absolutely nothing is impossible
watch your words they become your
actions watch your actions they become
your habit
hello elimination my name is Evan
Carmichael my one word believe it I
believe that entrepreneurs will solve
all of the world's major problems to the
help of your journey today we're going
to learn from the empowerment specialist
Cindy trip and my take on top 10 rule
number one is my personal favorite and I
love to know which ones you guys like to
buy and as always as you're watching
issues something that resonates with you
please leave it in the comments below
so folks or other people can be inspired
by kind of prizes as well and also when
you write it in much more likely to
stick to yourself as well
enjoy
we valuate the why the why yep the why
have you ever asked yourself the
question why haven't I done the things I
wanted to have you ever wondered why
others seem to get the breaks in life
and you were stuck in a dead-end job a
marriage that was over a long time ago a
condition that is debilitating you
physically emotionally mentally why
haven't you realized your dream or why
did you give up your personal power and
why are you feeling as if you're a
victim of circumstance and why do you
consider yourself a statistic a
demographic that other people are able
to benefit from but you can't benefit
from your own product a brand call you
why do you stay in that relationship
anyway that frustrates you and why do
you keep eating when you know the steps
that you have to take in order to be
healthy I think there's one reason and
that is because you or someone else has
convinced you that this is as good as it
gets
why did you buy into that life that
success and Happiness are are just four
story books or there is no
happy-ever-after
and if it's not one thing it's another
and why have you given up your dreams
anyway and why have you given up your
personal power so that someone else can
decide your destiny why have you done
this I believe that right now you could
be closer to your breakthrough when you
understand that I also am in the same
position when I recognized that God was
drawing me to a secret place Wow dr.
trim really I mean I thought you were
going to come out blazing with this big
revelation it is big because if you do
the same you're going to get the same
and sometimes you've got to center
yourself by taking some me moments most
of us take those me moments on the
telephone
with people who don't know where they're
going and then you're asking them how to
get to where you want to go if people
don't know where they're going they
cannot help you to find out how to get
where you're going and so I'm going to
challenge you today I'm going to
challenge you to have a Jacob experience
Jacob had to leave his family he had to
leave the familiar it was for a short
time he had to take some me moments and
wrestle he wrestled with himself he
wrestled with their why then you know I
think also many of us are afraid of
aloneness because we get a lowness mixed
up with loneliness there is a different
you know loneliness is the absence of
people alone this is the absence of
purpose and this is the big why if you
know the why then you can overcome any
how you can forever change the quality
of your life
the light that you lead by the words
that you speak have you ever felt that
you were trapped in a cycle and a
struggle of lack well you can get off of
that merry-go-round of poverty sickness
and depression and you can do it now
when you change your words you will
change your life one of the things that
I found out and the mistake that I made
in my life back in the day I can't
talking about the things that I didn't
want I don't want to be poor I don't
want this I don't want that talking
about and decree what you don't want
doesn't bring to you what you want and
this is why many of us are caught in
these kinds of storms we have health
storms financial storms relational
storms maybe some of what is going on is
not happening to us could it be that it
may be self-fulfilled prophecy negative
words bring about negative results
positive words healthy words successful
words prosperous words will do exactly
that
it will bring help it will bring
happiness it will bring success
and it will bring prosperity I want to
challenge you with one word the word
that is most important for any of us to
have it starts with a see I call it the
C word is that big word coverage all of
us need an extra dose of courage I
remember very clearly and as I think I
could still feel the butterflies in my
stomach of my stomach turning I was 15
years old I was in England and they said
we are going to show you how to excel it
looks so easy from where I was spending
I said I can ace that until I got to
that high point on the mountain they put
me there harness me up and they said go
all of a sudden the butterflies show up
I have absolutely no courage every ounce
of I can do it was drained out of me
when I look down to the bottom and I was
trying to figure out I have never done
this how am I going to get from the top
to the bottom
it started with putting one foot in
front of the others was I shaking
absolutely
I even had a tear coming down my eye but
with some coaching and with a lot of
cheering I tell you I learned how to
abseil to me courage is not saying that
you don't have fear it's not saying that
you don't have anxiety I had to face my
fear I had to feel it and I had to do it
anyway and that's what courage is all
about you ask yourself can I really do
this can i really go back to school
can I really heal after a broken
marriage can i really go on we all ask
those questions sometimes especially if
we've been through a storm a financial
storm an emotional storm a relational
stone or even a health storm when those
winds are blowing it seems as if we're
going to capsize in a sea
fear but hang on for one minute life is
made up of storms and I've learned from
sailing that it all depends on how you
are just your sails to me riding through
the storms getting courage starts right
here and right here do not listen to the
naysayers if you are going to have a
breakthrough you've got to be able to
silence the negative voices that's the
next step and that's the next secret
many of us have too many people speaking
into our ears I just call these people
abortionist so you've got to be careful
your dreams your visions your desires
especially those that have been
god-given I want you to pursue them I
want you to believe that all things are
possible it is possible for you to go
back to school it is possible for you to
heal your relationship it is possible
for you to go at life a loan it is
possible have you ever felt powerless
does it seem like you've lost control of
your life or like your life may be
spiraling out of orbit or maybe it feels
like everyone else around you is
successful or prosperous but it just
hasn't happened to you yet well I want
you to discover how to get the most out
of every single day of your life I want
you to regain that confidence and
control that you once had and I want you
to be able to squeeze every drop of the
life out of every single hour at every
second out of every single moment I want
you to know what it feels like to get up
out of it every single morning excited
and energized and ready to take on the
whole world
and you might act okay calm it down a
little bit how am I going to do that how
am I going to take off that powerless
feeling I promise you right here you
will have victory over this when you get
it under
sending of your true purpose purpose is
that a hidden seed of greatness and when
you know your purpose your life will
finally come right into focus listen I
woke up this morning excited in fact I
wake up every single day excited because
I know my life has direction and I know
where I'm going
purpose is the why that big why for you
being alive and when you find your why
the when the what the how takes care of
themselves when you discover your
purpose you will act decisively you will
accomplish your goals you're going to be
able to feel alive you're going to make
white wise choices you're going to know
what to say no to knowing what to say no
to gives you the ability to say yes what
you should say yes to and you want to
say yes to the right thing so when we
talk about purpose it is actually one of
the most important conversations we can
ever have so many people are living life
based on someone else's purpose why
would you want to be a refrigerator if
God has called you be a blender and
don't even think about being a blender
if God has called you to be a microwave
and you should not even want to be a
microwave if you're called to be a
washing machine in order to feel alive
you need to live a life on purpose in
order to feel successful in order for
you to gain prosperity in order for you
to overcome obstacles you need to
discover your purpose empowerment is one
of those words that's thrown around you
have empowerment specialists people all
over the place you see sides about
living the empowered life very few
people have explained to us what
empowerment is let me give you the just
simple definition of empowerment
empowerment simply means that you are
back in the driver's seat life does not
have to happen to you you can happen to
life here's the thing life comes at you
one day at a time and if you can just
learn how to live and
for that 24 hours then 24 years will not
be a problem when we talk about
empowerment a lot of people say okay if
I live the empowerment life what does
that feel like what does it look like to
me it means that when you wake up in the
morning you already have a plan for the
next 24 hours of the day and then you're
also able to deal with those bumps in
the road those turns in the road the
times when you don't feel like doing
what you know you should do empowerment
comes in handy stop procrastinating
focus on your goals when you focus on
what you want what you don't want or
automatically leave your life
don't focus on eliminating anything
focus on creating what you want so
you're either going to spend all your
energies eliminating what you don't want
or you spend your energies creating what
you want
we all have alibis we're all busy busy
doing what I'm going to challenge you
stay focus on your goals and if you
don't have goals write your goals one of
the greatest enemies of fulfillment of
purpose is procrastination and broken
focus if you start now and you say 365
days from today's date this is what I
want to accomplish and you do one add a
whole set focus this one thing I do I'm
focusing you do one a day at the end of
one year you will have made 365 towards
fulfillment of purpose who is not going
to be successful at the end of their
life who's not going to be prosperous at
the end of their life if they could
fulfill that nothing absolutely nothing
is impossible you can begin again you
can believe
eat god again you can trust again you
can be successful you can overcome your
addictions
you can ill you can feel alive again
this is when you realize that those
things are possible you are getting a
breakthrough so I want to encourage you
right now
don't give in go for it don't give up
don't throw in the towel and even if
your back is up against the wall even if
you are on the ropes and you are
receiving a rope but don't financially
listen you got to fight back you don't
get in life what you want you get what
you fight for and when you decide that
my future might help my marriage might
freedom my happiness my joy my peace my
children is worth fighting for you are
securing your breakthrough when it comes
to passion it's that thing that that
generates either the greatest joy or the
greatest sorrow passion to me is self
generated and it's a self generating
tool that you can use when times of
discouragement your passion is going to
get you up out of bed and it's going to
get you hitting at the streets and
pounding the pavement to bring that
vision to pass that passion you have the
ability to motivate yourself and that's
what passion is all about when you are
able to concentrate on your purpose to
maximize your potential and to live out
your dream when you do that you now hold
the secret right in your hand to live in
life not only on purpose but with
passion that's the thing that gets me
out of bed every single day the passion
for what I do
it gets me up in the morning it keeps me
going late at night and guess what I end
up going to bed very very seldom
exhausted and
I always go to bed excited I have to
tell myself better go to sleep
so that you could wake up in the morning
and sometimes they go to bed and I feel
like wow I almost don't want to go to
sleep because I don't want to miss out
on something that potentially and
possibly take me further into realizing
my dreams and goals one of the things
about passion is that it's an attitude
and your attitude sets the mood for
everyone everything around you they get
excited because you're excited
especially those people that work with
you and work for you if you are excited
about something and fascinated about
something then people's fascination and
excitement is turned on as well one of
the things that someone once said and
they said it like this chase down your
passion like it's the last bus of the
night this is what a guy by the name of
glad Adams and look at his name glad of
all names and he has the right to talk
about passion what you concentrate on
all day long determines your future now
here's the most important thing that if
you are able to concentrate your
thoughts one hour daily meditating
praying and thinking about the person
you would intend to do or the person you
intend to be or to become the places you
want to go the things you want to
accomplish what you want to invent
create the wealth you want to accumulate
the people with whom you want to network
the lines you will change the legacy you
will lead you will literally create in
your mind a clear picture of the
inevitable believe it or not and this is
going to fuel your daily activities as
well as what comes out of your mouth I
read somewhere one time watch your
thoughts they become your words watch
your words they become your actions
watch your actions they become your
habit what your have it they become your
character what your character if the
your destiny and it all starts with your
applause
they design so much for watching I mean
this video because internet hit
so there's a single chance for an event
if you are going to profound back check
out the link in the description you can
go and cast your vote
absolutely no which clips residence and
most of you was less me to take this
video and immediately apply to your life
or to business somehow leave it in the
comments below I'm really curious about
what you have to say I want to give a
quick charger to Stephanie no LSW think
you so much for finding a copy of my
book your one word and doing that nerd
evil in your sight I really really
appreciate it and I'm so happy to join I
thank you guys so much for watching I
believe in you hope we teach to believe
in yourself and whatever your one were
is much love
excess is a choice it is a choice to do
something it's a decision so if you
choose to do nothing you'll be
successful at that nothing but if you
choose to take a step in the right
direction and you be much much closer to
achieving your dreams so are you ready
to take that step this first step today
to trend from your life into our
victorious life I want you to take a
piece of paper out and I want you to
list the major projects that you want to
fulfill in a year's time I want you then
to prioritize them one two three and
four then I want you over the course of
three months finish one project not two
not three not four don't walk away from
here without creating that list and then
prioritizing and then starting now to
finish a task it could be if you could
start with small things like starting
that link and if you start the list and
you put four things down guess what you
have completed this first project give
yourself kudos and then go into the moon
it's great doing life I'm encouraging
you to do something so significant that
it will change your destiny positively
impact your family your community and an
industry and ultimately the course of
humanity
what would history be like if it wasn't
for the likes of people such as Hans
Christian Andersen and Abraham Lincoln
Florence Nightingale Christopher
Columbus the Wright brothers Marco Polo
George Washington Carver what was this
world be like had it not been for the
likes of Einstein Beethoven Harriet
Tubman Joan of Arc gin King Winnie
Mandela Cora Scott King these are the
people like Steven Biko who dares to
make a deal
Madame goo Young and Bishop TD jakes
then go Steven jobs and Walt Disney
what would this generation be like had
it not been for the likes of Martin
Luther King Nelson Mandela
Mohandas Gandhi Mary the mother of Jesus
these individuals refused to sit
insulated within the four walls of a
building or a church or a synagogue just
praying and wishing the world was
different they got up and they became
they change they wanted to see these are
the people that refuse to see themselves
as victims of circumstances or products
of their environment you know one of the
things I found out is this that these
people were just ordinary in their own
eyes they did something different
something unorthodox until they became
extraordinary in ours and that's what it
takes you cannot have extraordinary
without the ordinary and it takes that
to do something significant